welcome to hannity tonight a hannity
investigation into america's two-tier
justice system and corrupt d.c
politicians who excuse riots that don't
advance their political agenda now this
includes the clear danger this country
is now facing if roe v wade is
overturned we have left-wing groups now
signaling direct threats to riot we'll
tell you about that but first tonight we
begin with a major scam now ongoing
inside the climate alarmist religious
cult known as the new green deal
democratic party the socialist party and
as we speak the biden administration
they are knowingly and openly lying to
you the american people including their
own die hard supporters about one of the
democratic party's favorite causes the
transition to green renewable energy
remember they steadfastly refuse to
drill and to frack and they want to
import oil from iran and venezuela and
saudi arabia and opec watch
we have a chance here to make a
fundamental turn toward renewable energy
electric vehicles and not just electric
vehicles but across the board ultimately
we really do need to be investing in
renewables until we achieve a form of
energy independence that is based on
clean energy created here at home
american citizens will still be
vulnerable to wild price hikes like
we're seeing right now during putin's
war as minister
ryan has said this clean energy
transition
could be the peace project
of our time the way in which we can
ensure
reasonable energy expenses for
households is
to move to renewables to address climate
change
tonight we'll do a deep dive we'll
expose the truth about these lies
because as it turns out this push
towards what they call renewables and
green energy and electric cars is a
massive fraud we'll explain in detail
but in order to really understand this
it is important to first know where do
we get our energy from ever ask yourself
the question i know you come home you
flip on the lights ah electricity that's
great look at your screen 79
of america's grid is now powered by
guess what fossil fuels what do i say
about fossil fuels the lifeblood of the
world's economy that includes petroleum
natural gas and you bet coal another 8
is derived from nuclear power plants
liberals hate that too now currently
only 12
of our energy by definition would be
from renewables so if the administration
truly wanted to transition away from
fossil fuels they would need to shut
down 80 to 90 percent of our power grid
and replace it with what windmills solar
power unfortunately that type of
so-called green energy is not very
efficient let's take for example one
wind turbine it produces less than three
megawatts of energy whereas one natural
gas turbine produces 45 and get this a
typical natural gas plant has three
turbines which means you could need what
49 windmills to replace just one
moderately sized natural gas plant now
keep in mind there are more than 3 400
fossil fuel power plants in operation
within the u.s any transition to wind
and to solar would take decades and
decades and decades and it would not
lower the cost at all in the interim and
probably thereafter now each windmill
costs more than 3.8 million dollars to
build not to mention the thousands upon
thousands of acres of land that would be
needed to be purchased and as energy
secretary jennifer granholm declared
will require a lot of new resources that
you we the american people will have to
pay for take a look
with the president's goal of 100
clean electricity by 2035 and net zero
by 2050
we are going to be able to do that kind
of transition
uh with all different kinds of
technologies in all pockets of the
country we are going to need workers to
yes install wind turbines and solar
panels we're going to need workers to
build those wind turbines and solar
panels we need steel workers we need
miners for the materials to build them
we're going to need truckers and dock
workers and deck hands to to transport
them we're going to need electricians
we're going to need laborers we're going
to need utility workers
in other words a big transition to
renewables is not going to happen under
biden
and any incremental transition will do
nothing but drive up the cost of energy
all across the board the only actual way
to bring down prices is to produce more
gas and oil the lifeblood of the world's
economy i'll say it again in order to
appease the climate alarmist cult in his
party and pull the wool over your eyes
the administration is now trying to
outsource all energy needs overseas
that's why they're trying to do a deal
with iran that's why they're sending an
emissary emissaries over to venezuela
that's why he will bow before the crown
prince the guy that he says is
responsible for killing jamal khashoggi
the pariah nation of saudi arabia in
order to make another big show about
shutting down oil and gas infrastructure
like for example pipelines and
refineries and exploration permits
inside the u.s now that's why biden is
going to saudi arabia
in spite of what they say i promise you
he will be begging that crown prince
right there and kissing up to him and
kissing his ass and begging for more oil
production now we saw the same thing in
russia i'm sorry in europe with russia
far left germany well guess what they
have their own climate alarmist
religious cult they were desperate to
appease them they shut down their fossil
fuel facilities they outsourced all of
their energy needs and did
billion-dollar deals with vladimir putin
how's that working out ultimately was
all about optics didn't actually improve
the environment i mean mother earth
doesn't matter if you get a barrel of
oil from here or over here not really it
always was a huge scam and now with
putin's war raging germany well the
spigot's been shut off now they have to
restart their well mothball uh
coal-powered plants whoops see daisy now
this brings us to electric cars now pay
close attention here when the biden
administration isn't fantasizing about
renewables and and energy independence
with renewables they're begging
americans they're lecturing us to buy
electric cars they tell us over and over
again buy an electric car take a look
last month we announced a 5 billion
investment to build out a nationwide
electric vehicle charging network so the
people from rural to suburban to urban
communities can all benefit from the gas
savings of driving an ev under my plan
which is before the congress now we can
take advantage of the next generation of
electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about 80
a month
from not having to pay gas at the pump
it's on the issue of uh
gas prices after waiting for a long time
to have enough trips in this country to
finally get my electric vehicle i got it
and drove it from michigan to here uh
this last weekend and went by every
single gas station didn't matter how
high it was if you filled up your ev
by charging and you filled up your gas
tank with gasoline and you have the same
size tank you would save 60 dollars per
philip
by going electric rather than using
gasoline
maybe they haven't noticed but biden
inflation has added an additional six
thousand dollars to every american
household uh unnecessarily and as you
can see democrats want you to believe
you buy an electric vehicle it will
bring down the cost for you the american
people and will save the environment at
the same time
both claims are totally false let's
tackle the cost the obvious the average
price for a new electric vehicle is 64
000
compared to 44 000 for a full-size car
so from the purchase you're already well
20 grand in the hole add in another 1200
for an installation of an electric
charging port and 55 bucks a month in
additional energy costs and you will
most certainly not be saving any money
over the entire life of the vehicle i'm
not against them but i'm just giving you
the reality now of course any electric
car is only as clean as its energy
source they don't never talk about this
part remember eighty percent of our
power comes from oil gas and coal but
that's not the only thing to consider
keep in mind the production of these
electric vehicles not exactly
environmentally friendly you know the
battery alone is typically comprised of
nickel cobalt aluminum
manganese and all of these need to be
mined from mother earth with heavy
equipment that uses gas or diesel many
rechargeable batteries are derived from
oops china where they use slave labor or
child labor and don't get me wrong there
are some pretty cool electric vehicles
on the market including tesla by the way
i'd look at a tesla a friend of mine
swears by his he loves it but buying one
doesn't make you captain planet as john
kerry who flies around in his private
jets what have you believe and by the
way under trump the united states you
may have never been told this by the
climate alarmist cult
under donald trump the united states led
the world in greenhouse gas reduction
not because of electric cars or
windmills instead clean burning
affordable natural gas developed through
the free market help the united states
curb pollution by the way
we're the middle east of natural gas we
have at least 200 plus years worth of a
supply of natural gas and that's all we
know about at this moment now talking
about a phantom transition to renewables
is not going to save our economy or the
planet we are now barreling towards a
recession coupled with out-of-control
inflation the national gas tax holiday
biden is now proposing will not
significantly bring down prices i'll
take it 18.4 cents a gallon but i'll
take it but even obama said that
this is a gimmick kind of like tapping
into the strategic petroleum reserve
it's a band-aid it's a temporary fix
after the election they'll put it back
in place take a look
oil companies like shell and bp just
reported record profits for the quarter
and we're arguing over a gimmick to save
you half a tank of gas
over the course of the entire summer so
that everyone in washington can pat
themselves on the back and say that they
did something
i can't believe it obama for once is
actually right meanwhile obama's former
economic advisor
larry summers is now not only predicting
a recession also warning that the u.s
would need five years or six percent
unemployment or one year of 10
unemployment to ease inflation biden
inflation our economy is going into a
very dark place you see it with your
401k you see it when you go to the gas
pump and you see it in every store that
you shop in and by the way the white
house press secretary wasn't exactly
reassuring take a look
the action that the president has taken
with the american rescue plan
with what we have seen with the
historical gains
that is going to help us deal
with the recession right now we don't
see a recession right now that is not
we're not in a recession right now
right now we're in a transition where we
will we are
going to go into a place of stable and
steady growth the president has been
very clear in making sure that he does
everything that he can
to uh to elevate to alleviate uh the
you know the the pain that american
families are feeling when it comes to
gas prices
america is not heading towards a
recession that's kind of like inflation
is transitory we the american people are
not stupid now the americans now know
that how supply and demand works they
know that lecturing oil and gas
companies and restricting the domestic
production of energy raising taxes is
not going to bring down costs or save us
from a recession and by the way now in a
new poll biden's approval rating is at
32 percent that's right the lowest point
in a presidency since
1948. hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else